okay so a new update for rainbow six
siege is on the horizon
literally it's called operation neon
dawn and because they're beauties
ubisoft gave us the chance both to play
test it
and grill one of the devs about the new
defender the skyscraper rework
some ever so juicy operator changes and
their overarching plan
to fix siege's so-called 20-second meta
because while it may not seem like it at
first this update is actually step
one of that plan
[Music]
okay so before we jump into the new
operation which i'm psyched to tell you
guys about
i have to remind you to please like the
video please sub to our channel and if
you want more siege donates like this
one
where we cover new operations please hop
down into the comments and let us know
it helps us and me specifically know
what kind of siege content you guys want
okay so when it comes to operation neon
dawn there are definitely some things
worth talking about
like the fact that it has this whole
dream punk aesthetic and like kind of
sick ass stranger things theme
my gate stands like a star in the
darkness
a burning light that keeps enemies at
bay
can you take the heat
first things first we got a brand
spanking new operator
named a rooney in short she's a two
speed two armored defender
who's got mozzie's roni dokabee's dmr
barbed wire and a bulletproof cam her
primary gadget is this
badass laser force field that can be
fitted on hatches
walls windows and doorways
it damages attackers upon entry but
turns off if defenders get within a
certain proximity
meaning that they can't play close
around it the way they would a shield or
a mira window
it also destroys both drones and
projectiles unless attackers are able to
navigate them through this kind of
weird slot at the bottom making her a
kind of weird hybrid between
jaeger kapkan castle and mozzie
here's the thing though it isn't static
as soon as something touches it it
deactivates for a short time
meaning that attackers could essentially
sacrifice a single drone to disable the
force
field and rush sight that said it is
indestructible
meaning that you need to play fast in
order to counter it
it's hard to say how useful she'll be as
of right now but she definitely seems
very strong especially since she has
really stellar weapons for taking both
short and long range engagements
now i know what you're thinking yay
another trap operator
i admit at first glance a rooney does
seem to pose a lot of the same
annoyances that
lucy does and initially i wasn't really
sure why ubisoft thought that this would
be a good solution to siege's so-called
20-second meta now for those who don't
know the 22nd meta refers to the fact
that for a
frustratingly long time now the trend in
pro play has been for attackers to spend
the entirety of the round clearing
utility
only to rush the site in a fit of
desperation with 20 seconds to go
but i got a chance to sit down with
emeliane lomnet
one of siege's most recognizable game
devs and he tackled this issue
head on we know that sadly the timing
of irony is in the heart of the 22nd era
well at its worst at its peak right now
so the idea was like okay no no we're
still gonna go with irony we don't
really have much of a choice but we're
gonna make sure that we're gonna define
roles for opera that can catch
projectiles to prevent their ability to
just deny everything
first he assured me that a rooney
wouldn't be too
oppressive which having played her i
believe
but more importantly he explained to me
how irony
and operation neon dawn as a whole are
actually the first step in ubisoft's
multi-step plan
to dismantle the 22nd meta entirely
we have a lot of ideas i can't really
discuss all of them because one of the
important facts about this
addressing the 22nd meta is going to be
a multi-step process this is step one
and we know that step one is not going
to make it go away
day one but the plan is over the next
few months to have more
stuff coming in to address it and
eventually i can guarantee you that
soon-ish the twin second meta is a thing
of the past now this brings us to the
slew of nerfs reworks
and quality of life changes that
actually makes operation neon dawn kind
of a godsend
in terms of operator reworks they made
it so that hibana can control the number
of pellets she uses per x-kairos
discharge
helping her to remain what emeliane
termed the queen of the hatches
now that's cool but not nearly as cool
as the fact that they
finally nerfed jaeger's ads
ads now have an infinite number of zaps
instead of just two
the catch is that now there's a cooldown
in between each of them
meaning that you only have to burn one
flash to disable it they also made it so
that echoes yokais are
always visible which is great because
echo one of the dreaded issues with the
20-second meta is just how frequently
attackers find themselves being
hard countered by defender utility and
the feeling of
helplessness that that evokes this
helplessness feeling is the heart of the
22nd meta
it's it's not like the heart of being
bulletproof is not the issue itself is
stacking all of those things where if
you don't have the exact combination of
counter
it's two elements obviously i don't have
the right counter plus
i don't have enough of them which is
also the 20 second meta is like
even even if i brought ash and zlushia i
still don't have
enough this is something that amelian
and i talked about and he explained that
by
implementing more soft counters siege
can hopefully become a little bit more
about outplaying your opponent
as opposed to just drowning in a sea of
seemingly indestructible utility
pretty much anything in your arsenal
including your own body
can deal with the gate and that's this
philosophy of like okay all counters can
be nice sometimes
but we need way more granularity on how
to tackle
gadgets in the game and irony is exactly
that and only one of the key
uh aspects of heroni for us is like she
is
really interesting at receiving the map
but we want everyone to counter it
essentially
the goal of course is to provide
attackers with some much needed
breathing room
they gave ash a third breaching round
for instance though it did come at the
cost of her flashes
which as a cs player actually makes me
big sad
even though they're [ __ ] this takes us
to what is possibly
the best change of the entire update
they
have the run out timer from two seconds
to one second
oh baby do i love this change look
we're big fans of coconut bra over at
the score esports
but i think i speak for all of us when i
say
get in all seriousness
run outs are sick and to remove them
entirely from siege would destroy the
soul of the game
but it was starting to feel certainly in
ranked
as if valk screaming out of a barricade
every two seconds was becoming
central to siege gameplay and not just a
facet of it
next the map rework skyscraper
oh skyscraper it's safe to say that if
you were a fan of the old skyscraper you
were
a bad person so what did they change and
were they successful in making it a
little bit less of
an awful inescapable claustrophobic
hellscape where siege went to die
having only played a handful of rounds
on it i can't say for sure
what i can say for sure is that i was
very surprised at how much i liked it it
felt
open maneuverable and had this old siege
vibe that the old skyscraper
never did which is something that amelia
and i got to discuss
every time you attack skyscraper or you
define you you essentially have one
option
you're always gonna do the same thing
it's also a very frustrating map for a
lot of newcomers because it's a map that
is
very open to incredible number of
runouts
and it's both the level design thing and
also connected to what i was saying it
was just before
because since you have no option no
interesting thing to do as a defender
the only interesting thing you can do on
skyscraper is run out
whereas the new version is there to
introduce a lot more options
for the attacking team and thus for the
different team as well
and uh and that was what was very
important for us to like bring her into
this
more creative mindset you want to know
the best part about the new skyscraper
though
okay come here closer come on a little
closer i'm gonna asmr this [ __ ] for you
it's replacing outback in ranked
replacing outback beyond that the most
significant changes that neon dawn
brought with it were little nips and
tucks to the overall flow of gameplay
for example they reduced the amount of
time that it takes for a defender to put
up a reinforcement
which actually slaps like
does that feel so good oh also good news
for all of you ash and zofia meaning
bolo wannabes
they finally made it so that if and when
you actually decide to destroy a piece
of utility
you can shoot your charges straight onto
things like maestro cams and they won't
ricochet off
most of the other changes are fairly
granular like you can't defuse the bomb
from outside the room on certain sites
anymore but the big takeaway from this
update
is that ubisoft are keenly aware of the
so-called
20-second meta and have big plans as to
how they're going to fix it
now amelian couldn't exactly divulge
what those plans were of course since
a lot of it is still under wraps but
from what i could gather
ubisoft is very aware of the community's
concerns
and are hard at work trying to rectify
them
and that's that's your toaster that's my
toaster yeah the darth vader head the
darth vader head
yeah yeah i have star wars [ __ ] like up
on the wall over there my clock and
you can't see it i didn't actually
realize you were a star wars fan oh i'm
a big star wars fan yeah i'm just not a
psychopath like colin who like hates joy
i actually also like star wars but i
just i don't really
like know how to participate in any part
of those conversations
the way you do it is by not
participating in the conversations
that are anything beyond this is
literally a franchise that was designed
to give 12 year olds joy
and it's really fun going into a theater
and being 12 again
that's literally all it is like yeah
there are things like like the third new
one was like really [ __ ] bad
and like he was [ __ ] it was bad like you
can [ __ ] on that movie it's fine
and like the [ __ ] phantom menace is
like a nightmare like it's an absolute
[ __ ] show of course